so chris what are your new year's
resolutions for this year
to be on trash tastes third time
the first time a third time after this
after this wow well you are the first
guest of uh 2021
and the first reoccurring guest and i
got my thing up on the wall
i love you guys especially how do you
feel with next though
all these like uh little more elaborate
squishies i
put a lot more effort into theirs than i
did i look like i was
like scribbling at the last minute
before i got on a train or something
new year's resolution get into shape i
think i sat every year
everywhere i mean that's like the most
generic year's resolution anyone could
uh
are you actually going to though i would
do something really bold right okay
i'm going to say i want to make natsuki
famous
my good friend that's that's it i would
argue that natsuki is kind of already
feeling like
world level global tom cruise level
famous
is that possible how would you go about
doing something like that i think at
first
you would have to get to that point
right you said i'm not world famous
chris [ __ ] hell jerry that's a lot
isn't it jesus christ
it just takes longer to be in a hospital
by the end of this oh
for hers as well oh is it smell good
interesting fact depending on how you
drink sake like in a cup or a glass it
smells and taste differently
that's kind of like how wide your nose
is over the glass you get more of the
scent
commonly commonly known
somebody's going to destroy me in the
comments he's wrong about everything
um it's okay no nobody comes here for an
actual moment
see how this tastes then chris if you've
got [ __ ] taste so you've got the trash
taste
that's uh that's very smooth that goes
down smoothly
it's very like james bond where they
have to say the title of the bond film
every time
have you guys ever had a new year's
resolution come off here oh my god
that's good that costs like twelve
dollars twelve dollars
he's being a baby that's exactly that's
expensive for psychedelic something
these samsung bottles like four bucks
no expense spared for you it tastes like
a sour
barrel oh so thank you chris that
cultural appropriation
you're disrespectful
you disgust
it's not bad it's not bad it's just it's
i totally drink like
strong liquor
i'm a bit of a little [ __ ] with that
stuff i won't lie i'll do a shot
reluctantly
but you know when we go out to yeah
cigar bar or whatever
we'll go
oh my god chris come on so we'll go and
these boys will be like we have to get
whiskey because we're
civilized men you know and i'm like i'll
have the pinkish strength that you have
and i have no problem with doing that
because i know what i like chris does
the drink name have the word
[ __ ] in it i'll have it which one has
glitter in it tell me that
have you brought out your own like trash
taste sucker yet no
no all right is that is that something
you could hook up for us chris do you
know a guy you know
can we actually do that with each person
yeah wait christopher
we need to do that for a special and
have crispy the the chief taste tester
i would be up for that you wouldn't of
course you could do that okay okay
i've actually looked into like crafting
my own beer and your own wine and
apparently
it's illegal in japan yeah apparently
even though
you can buy kits in japan but it's
illegal to make it but you can buy the
kits well what the [ __ ] you do with the
kids
pop it up on the shelf it's like
surprised like a sake building kit all
right
it's like they have uh like radios as
well yeah we did uh we got
walkie-talkies
the laws in japan are really strict with
walkie-talkies given that you can't use
some frequencies
half the [ __ ] on amazon in japan is like
the illegal frequencies
and it's like why are these being sold
what good guards
did you get like police on it why are
you you could you could you might
accidentally get like the police like
picking you up you know it'd be
like the fbi would be pretty scary
wouldn't it so you're on the other end
of it
or would you like to see your ass and
then a police officer police officers
like
talking [ __ ] to you oh my god i think i
was trying to ask this earlier but have
you guys ever had a new year's
resolution that you've actually kept to
or like have you guys actually had a new
year's resolution i did actually have
one to lose weight and i did actually
lose weight that year how much
[ __ ] you chris uh i think i lost
eight kilograms that year eight
kilograms yeah it's pretty good
oh was that the yeah
[Music]
you know you were saying like oh yeah i
want to leave look at my old videos
like i have old photos of you and like
you're in some of my old videos as well
and back then i was like no he's
he's fine he looks like a healthy way
but then i look at you now
why are you laughing at my meals chris
chicken and broccoli everything yeah
it was depressing it was [ __ ] awful
again
200 days
i pretty much just i was like all right
the highlight of my day
was the protein shake which was somewhat
sweet i was like oh this is amazing
oh dude i'm chicken and broccoli in it
it would be like white chocolate protein
shake and it would not taste like white
chocolate and then i would go home and
be depressed and
eat and cook [ __ ] chicken broccoli
like the fifth time
that week i just imagine you like in the
supermarket your trolleys just for
nothing
my roommate hated it because i it would
take turns cooking right right
so they would cook something and i you
know if it was if it was not not very
good for you all right fine you know
but then i'd be like guess what we're
having tonight
guess what i'm making tomorrow chicken
and broccoli it's the connor specialty
it's steamed chicken and broccoli i
think that should be your resolution
this year
on a daily basis for the whole year to
be fair
not not that difficult because in the in
the family mart you can get those
chicken tikka breaks so did you like mix
up the dish
every day like one day it was like
chicken and broccoli in a curry next day
no it was just oh my god it's literally
just
chicken and i would i would boil the
broccoli and i would chuck the chicken
uh in the oven with uh with some like
piri piri like seasoning
and that was it every day a sea dog va
i cookbook okay it's it's like it's
tough because at the time i think the
problem is now is that i socialize
because i think when you act when you
actually have
friends that you go out with because in
the uk you don't actually go out that
much with your friends
like i think i think it's a it's a bit
of an event in the uk it's more of like
a weekend thing
right but yeah yeah yeah whereas moving
to japan especially as you do in the
week a lot
yeah you go out during the week or even
if it's just good to go out for like
lunch or dinner
yeah i think i meet people for lunch or
dinner at least three times a week now
yeah
and like it's so hard to diet when
you're going out and you're having
lunches and you're
you know because normally when you have
lunch on your own you might have a
sandwich you go to a restaurant to have
lunch it's always just it's so [ __ ]
much
why why have you got that face it's
chicken broccoli
[Laughter]
so if you don't socialize it's really
easy to just feed yourself [ __ ]
garbage and just like you'd be like
[ __ ] chicken and broccoli yeah
i mean in the uk you go out to me a mate
and it's either a sesh
or harder sesh or like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
giant curry
or a kebab you know and you [ __ ] kill
yourself but if you're at home you know
it's really easy to
just eat a lot of broccoli i could
probably eat chicken and broccoli
because peri-peri seasoning honestly
like
yeah because like when you said like
chicken and broccoli i thought like no
like maybe like salt and pepper yeah
salt pepper yeah of course
seasoning or like some kind of like
marinate then it's a little better not
much i would i would buy this like
pre-packaged garbage and it would like
you would have to put it on the chicken
before you cooked it right and they
would say like oh it would be
in the picture it looked like absolutely
coated but what would end happening is
one splodge of this chicken would have a
[ __ ] ton of seasoning
and the rest of the chicken was bone dry
because i just burnt the [ __ ] out of it
i got i got desperate the other day and
i was like really missing i was really
missing
i was really missing nando's i looked up
i looked up if there was like anywhere
you could import nando's sauce
there was like 50 quid for a bottle of
nando's stores
and i i was just like and i clicked the
buy button
i've never felt so disappointed on
myself that i've gotten to the point
where i've spent
50 quid to buy a bowl of nano sauce how
much how much sauce are we talking like
it's like it's it's like a medium bottle
so it's like it's not even that big
i was i was just missing nando so much i
miss perry perry man
i miss my periphery chicken how much
wealth is too much
it'll be worth it when you plop it on
your feed pop it on your switch
what's the chris broad diet then if
you're mocking my my chicken and
broccoli
you're just [ __ ] winging it just
every day you wake up you're like [ __ ]
it might have a
chicken tikka the only thing i can cook
is omelettes so it's either that's it
or more or omelettes wait so what are
you what are you eating when you're
dieting that
isn't it just omelette every meal
you like it's like oh it's five o'clock
you know what time that is another
omelette
you can mix it up then you have like
cheese in it you can have chicken cheese
on your diet
chicken and broccoli omelette you
shouldn't be having cheese when you're
dieting chris come on that's
awful for you cheers
you know you know would spice up an
omelette
chicken and broccoli take the trash
taste diet ladies and gentlemen
broccoli for a week you don't you don't
lose on chicken and broccoli chris you
just wait
you should try a chicken and broccoli
omelette next yeah do my next
i also i also uh followed this strange
youtube guide that was like
it was apparently this this uh soup that
would make you lose weight because it
would have
negative calories what um but you would
have like a mad fast
well essentially yeah because you would
put okay okay wait wait wait wait how
would you have
negative calories so the ingredients in
it would actually make you
like were so like salary for example
right it was had a lot of celery in it
so you would end up
actually took more calories to
quote-unquote eat like
digest it than it was to eat it really
and i would make this giant thing of it
it was it was just a bunch of [ __ ]
vegetables like
onions cabbage like fine because you
would put like
uh onion um onion soup powder in it and
like
a can of tin tomatoes so it just tastes
like a shitty minestrone soup
right but you would have like a giant
[ __ ] bowl of this [ __ ] and you're
like oh my god
oh my god 20 minutes later your stomach
is still full but you're like i'm hungry
i'm so hungry and you're full but you're
like you're farting non-stop as well
it's awful
i couldn't stop farting all the calories
yeah and
the comments on this video are all about
how people cannot stop farting
and about how it's causing problems
that's
that's what you use all the calories for
like the violent [ __ ] honestly it was
embarrassing i was on like the train
like i i just every time i managed to
hold one in 10 seconds later another one
would claw its way out
i was like sorry just give up and start
farting
because i was also trying to exercise as
well and there's nothing worse than
needing to fart while you're running
because how do you you because when
you're where you're
because because when you're sitting down
you can kind of like
you can engage your videos you can kind
of like you
like massage it out of your cheeks but
you're farting
when you're running it's like do i just
let this boy come out at full speed
but then you realize the treadmill's so
[ __ ] loud that you're like just fart
away yeah no one's gonna care
disgrace that's disgraceful
there's no way they'll hear because i'm
[ __ ] on the treadmill
well i've told you my new year's
resolution but like and you said like
is there a resolution you keep the only
way is to do like become a better person
keep it vague right and then you can
decide the parameters on the phone
how many how many times if it's at that
point then you might as well just say
stay alive and become a better person
eat food i'm going to eat this take your
[ __ ]
what's your resolution i never really
like made resolutions because
like i used to when i was little because
my entire family was i was like i guess
i
have to make one too yeah but then i
don't think i've ever kept a resolution
my entire life
i don't know maybe maybe it's because
i'm too over ambitious with my
resolutions like what
the most resolution you've ever seen
my new year's resolution this year is to
do a video with chris broad on my
channel
but i don't know what the [ __ ] to do
with you chris broccoli and chicken and
broccoli
[Laughter]
who makes the best omelette have you
ever heard of homeless before